moundir n'est pas plus fort que le coc
vide je crois que la lumière par rapport
aux qu'ovide c'est pas sur moi qu'il
faut la mettre mais sur les gens qui
m'ont sauvé ces femmes qui m'ont laver
qui m'ont aidé et qui m'ont massé qui
vont essuyer qui m'ont motivé à me lever
du lit
merci à vous tous là tous les internes
des hôpitaux publics
vous m'avez sauvé la vie
[Musique]
on a toujours des regrets
à vis des regrets vis-à-vis de koh lanta
peut-être à l'époque quand je me suis
emporté
effectivement disons que la colère était
justifié mais pas ma façon de parler
donc lina si tu vois cette interview je
t'aime très fort
vrai le drop shipping et est un métier
légal ce que je n'aime pas ce sont les
gens qui font de ce métier du vol et qui
mettent des familles en péril heureux
est vrai pour les vrais dropship heures
par contre pour les drogues sheepers
kamer non mais je suis contre ça
alors faut 28 ans hors taxes qui fait 47
ttc 147g moi j'aurais aimé avoir 28 ans
malheureusement je les ai déjà fait est
qu'aujourd'hui ben je me rapproche plus
des 50 que d'être ans
basketteur semi professionnel j'ai vécu
des années magiques
la vie en a décidé autrement un scooter
me renverse fractures ouvertes double
fracture du tibia et là il faut il faut
réfléchir parce que je n'ai pas de
métier je me retrouve avec une main
devant une main derrière
papa
alors je suis pas un influenceur j'aime
j'aime partager des choses forcément sur
sur mes réseaux j'aime mettre en avant
aussi des sociétés françaises avec
lesquelles je discute auparavant donc je
ne suis pas un influenceur à 100%
vraiment je ne suis pas tous les jours
en train de photographier tout ce que je
fais
vrai je ne suis pas un corrompu ni un
lâche
voilà et avec beaucoup de leur phare
contre voilà
bon la vie y'a que des gens que des
pommes sur un pommier ne nous écoute
indochine ouais on va dire faux
info à tapha droit de dire ça tu
respectes star wars retour du jeudi
retour du vendredi parce que ç'a été
toute ma vie moi ça a été toute ma vie l
empire contre attaque oeuvre la guerre
des étoiles et autour du jedi
non non ça a été ça a été toute ma vie
ouais même en faux faux faux je suis pas
je suis pas célibataire je suis
maintenant depuis douze ans avec trois
enfants
et d'ailleurs je les aime très fort et
ma femme je t'aime
ouais je
je n'ai jamais été prétentieux dans un
sens ou où c'était gratuit j'avais
énormément dégoût à l'époque 2003 quand
j'avais fait mon premier koh lanta
aujourd'hui j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle
une mise à jour
s'il obtient longtemps effectivement je
me sens mieux aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque
aa faut de l'image du csp
faux j'ai quitté mon émission moundir et
les apprentis aventuriers aussi w9
parce qu'on me proposait pas un plan de
carrière j'avais besoin de signer sur
plusieurs années ce qu'on me proposait
pas
le coc vider est une maladie qui fait
peur il faut vivre avec
malheureusement moi j'ai été touché
gravement jeu j'en garde encore des
séquelles parce que je suis encore en
rémission convalescence si vous voulez
et voilà ça maintenant ça fera partie de
ma vie
j'espère qu'il sera derrière mais en
tout cas j'ai eu des moments où
effectivement la peur a fait partie a
fait partie de du fait que j'ai accepté
mon destin
ça fait bien longtemps que je suis pas
allé chez le coiffeur
en plus avec les cheveux longs que j'ai
je ne sais pas douze ans cette légende
moundir pistonné non au contraire
vous désirez travailler beaucoup il
travaille beaucoup pour aller chercher
ce qu'il a ce qu'il a construit ça
n'existe pas le piston
j'adore les fleurs les cactus tout ce
qui pique voilà tout ce qui est attirant
tout ce qu'ils attrapent tout ce qui
agrippe
faux michael de michael jackson
intemporel peut pas le côté c'est le
graal
le graal
[Musique]